[Musique]
le château de Chantilly est le symbole
de l'excellence française en matière
d'architecture
[Musique]
situé à 50 km au nord de Paris l'édifice
trône depuis un millénaire au sommet des
plus belles constructions de France
chantilly c'est exceptionnel c'est le
plus extraordinaire des patrimoine
français on a tous que l'architecture et
l'art des jardins a fait de plus beau en
France au cours des siècles
un château monumental d'une superficie
totale de 10.000 mètres carrés autant
que le palais de l'Élysée un parc tout
aussi gigantesque le grand parterre de
Chantilly en superficie c'est 6 terrains
de football 12 km de perspective c'est
la plus grande perspective de France
encore aujourd'hui
les écuries princières les plus grandes
d'Europe
c'est la même longueur que la façade des
Invalides cette démesure fera même de
Chantilly le rival du plus beau château
du monde
c'est un petit Versailles
nous allons vous raconter le chantier de
cette demeure monumentale
où chaque étape de construction fut un
combat ça a été un effort énorme pour
les équipes qui ont dû travailler ici
même à l'heure actuelle on déconseille
fortement voir en interdit la
construction sur sur ces zones à
Chantilly on peut pas construire comme
ailleurs à Chantilly il faut innover
des fondations sur pilotis au symétrie
des jardins à la française
en passant par la création d'un dôme
colossal comment les bâtisseurs ont-ils
pu défier l'impossible
quel prouesse technique réalisée au 17e
siècle par le plus grand paysagiste de
France André Le Nôtre permettra à
Chantilly de dépasser Versailles
à Chantilly qui avait les fontaines qui
marchaient en continu je ne sais pas si
vous imaginez l'effet que ça a pu faire
à Louis XIV
grâce à des animations 3D inédites et
aux témoignages des plus grands
spécialistes nous remonterons 10 siècles
de travaux titanesques
du château fort médiéval à la demeure
princière d'aujourd'hui
voici l'histoire de l'une des
constructions les plus époustouflantes
de France miraculée de l'histoire
le château de Chantilly
chantilly est un château qui cache bien
son jeu
connu aujourd'hui pour ces mythiques
courses de chevaux
c'est 815 peinture qui en font la
deuxième plus grande collection de
tableaux anciens après le Louvre
chaque année c'est plus d'un demi
million de visiteurs qui vient déambuler
à travers un domaine de 7000 hectares
soit autant que Paris intra-muros
et pourtant beaucoup l'ignorent
méchantillis n'a pas toujours été aussi
raffiné et ordonné qu'aujourd'hui bien
au contraire
en fait l'histoire de Chantilly est une
histoire faite de destruction et de
reconstruction incessante
pour décrypter les nombreuses vies de
cette construction il nous faut remonter
le temps de plus d'un millénaire
nous sommes au 11e siècle en plein Moyen
Âge
à l'époque le royaume de France n'est
pas encore unifié sa capitale royale
Senlis
situé à 45 km au nord de Paris et la
cible de nombreuses attaques
l'époque est pas très sûre et donc il
faut des points défensifs tout autour de
cette cité à plusieurs lieux de distance
plusieurs kilomètres on va trouver comme
ça des forteresses qui sont censés
protéger sans lisses sur la route qui
mène de Paris à la Picardie
mais un emplacement pose problème pour
la construction d'une forteresse
celui de la forêt de Chantilly à 7 km de
Senlis
c'est des marécages venu plus ni moins
de la tourbe des arbres sauvages
[Musique]
c'est un territoire agricole sur un
plateau traversé par une vallée la
vallée de la rivière Nonette qui est une
vallée marécageuse
cette rivière appelée La Nonette est un
cours d'eau de plusieurs mètres de large
mais au débit très faible seulement 1,8
m3
alors qu'elle sera un atout incroyable
quelques siècles plus tard notamment
pour concurrencer le château de
Versailles au Moyen-Âge elle est
extrêmement contraignante pour les
bâtisseurs
c'est extrêmement boueux il faut aller
jusqu'à 10 mètres de profondeur avant
notre trouver un rocher pour sur
lesquels on peut se fonder mais à
l'époque en fait creusé sur 10 mètres
c'était tout juste c'était un défi qui
était absolument pas possible
même à l'heure actuelle on déconseille
fortement voir en interdit la
construction sur sur ces zones
mais une découverte va tout changer
heureusement au milieu de cette vallée
marécageuse il y a un éperon rocheux
enfin une masse rocheuse qui va
permettre de construire un château à
l'époque médiévale
c'était énorme rocher calcaire à la
géométrie irrégulière sera donc la base
du futur château fort
[Musique]
mais avant de débuter la construction de
nombreux défis attendent les bâtisseurs
ça va demander du travail d'arrasement
au bâtisseurs il faut essayer d'aplanir
le rocher pour qu'il puisse être
l'assise solide sur laquelle vont se
dresser les parois les courtines
[Musique]
seulement muni d'une pioche les
constructeurs creusent autour et sur le
rocher pour dégager un socle épuré
ils ont dû creuser dans le rocher
extrêmement dur pour encercler le
château d'eau pour faire de sorte que le
château soit complètement entouré assez
complexe que faire à Sion c'est un
travail très pénible
[Musique]
cet entaille permet de récupérer plus de
7000 mètres cubes de pierre soit de quoi
remplir plus de 200 conteneurs
un stock colossal bien utile pour
construire les premières maçonneries
[Musique]
le rocher on en profite pour avoir une
petite pierre qui va servir aussi à
l'intérieur des maçonneries
et de la pierre il en faut à Chantilly
car à l'époque les bâtisseurs ont
l'habitude de doubler l'épaisseur des
murs
à l'époque il construisait pour que ça
dure il faisait pas forcément ta
l'économie pour deux raisons
premièrement le château était devait
être solide au début au Moyen-Âge pour
résister éventuellement à des attaques
et il faut le dire en quelque sorte
c'était aussi par ignorance
il ne savait pas jusqu'au il pouvait
réduire l'épaisseur des murs des
matériaux pour que ça tienne donc il
doublait triplet pour être sûr que ça
tienne et comme ça effectivement le
résultat est que ils ont construit des
choses qui sont beaucoup trop solides
[Musique]
ici les murs des soubassements ne font
pas moins de 3 mètres d'épaisseur
de quoi permettre la construction d'un
véritable château fort défensif
chantilly est né
il y avait 7 tours à Chantilly qui
montait très haut et vous avez des
courtines des murs entre ces tours qui
montaient aussi haut que c'est tout et
cela permettait d'accueillir
l'artillerie
[Musique]
preuve de la qualité extraordinaire des
constructeurs de l'époque les
soubassements médiévaux servent encore
de fondation à l'actuel château
[Musique]
c'est ce que nous révèle Pierre Antoine
Gatier architecte en chef des Monuments
Historiques
pour la chance que nous avons avec la
lumière rasante on voit toutes les
traces d'outils des marques de tâcherons
quasiment chaque pierre était
identifiable par ces marques rien qui
sont la mémoire de l'organisation du
chantier la mémoire de ces tailleurs de
pierre très très habiles chaque tailleur
de pierre avait sa marque et marqué les
pierres avec un petit signe qui montrait
que c'est lui qui avait coupé la pierre
et comme ça les ouvriers étaient payés
au fur et à mesure du travail qu'ils
avaient fourni
[Musique]
les vestiges médiévaux les plus visibles
ce sont d'une part les douves et d'autre
part la base des tours du château fort
sur ces deux bases de tour on voit qu'il
y a encore des archères qui sont en
place c'est-à-dire des fentes verticales
allongées qui permettaient depuis
l'intérieur de la tour de tirer pour se
défendre contre les assauts des
aiguilles
et ce n'est pas tout le public
d'aujourd'hui l'ignore mais l'héritage
médiéval le plus marquant à Chantilly
est ailleurs il faut prendre de la
hauteur pour le voir c'est le plan du
château
[Musique]
une sorte de triangle équilatéral de 70
mètres de côté qui est depuis un
millénaire la matrice architecturale de
Chantilly
quel que soit l'époque de construction
tous les bâtisseurs devront un
manquablement repartir de ce premier
plan plus ou moins triangulaire que vont
élaborer les premiers bâtisseurs à
l'époque médiévale sur cette épreuve
un plan qui va poser des problèmes au
16e siècle quand le nouveau propriétaire
de Chantilly voudra transformer le
château fort en demeure princière
flamboyante
[Musique]
150 ans après le Moyen Âge en 1560 une
nouvelle campagne de grands travaux et
sur le point d'être lancé à chantilly à
la demande du nouveau maître des lieux
un certain Anne de Montmorency
[Musique]
un prénom masculin c'est un peu
déroutant pour nous mais c'est bien un
homme
et cet homme n'est pas n'importe qui
c'est l'une des personnes les plus
puissantes de France au 16e siècle
il est connétable autrement dit le chef
suprême des armées
et il est immensément riche
[Musique]
Montmorency était quand même
propriétaire de 600 fiefs et de 130
châteaux et seigneurie plus des hôtels
particuliers dans Paris et on sait qu'il
était très féru d'architecture et ce
personnage essentiel qui va avoir des
possessions dans toute la France va
faire de Chantilly sa principale
résidence et ça va être un tournant pour
l'histoire de Chantilly vraiment avec
des chantiers immenses qui vont être
menées
[Musique]
des chantiers qui vont très vite devenir
un casse-tête pour les ouvriers
car après avoir ajouté des fenêtres à la
forteresse médiévale le commanditaire
veut l'agrandir pour recevoir les plus
grands rois de France et d'Europe
donc il faut s'imaginer que la cour de
France qui se déploie c'est plusieurs
milliers de personnes qui bougent on
trouve que le château est un peu petit
on veut l'agrandir on est assez
contraint par les 7 tours et la forme
triangulaire
[Musique]
on va avoir sans arrêt à Chantilly le
besoin de trouver de l'espace
et ce n'est pas le seul problème que
pose la forteresse médiévale
[Musique]
le connétable veut également que son
château respecte les codes
architecturaux de la Renaissance
à l'époque les nouvelles constructions
arborent une architecture parfaitement
symétrique comme ici à Chambord tout le
contraire de Chantilly
donc c'est vraiment une disposition qui
a selon les mots des hommes de la
Renaissance une sauvage cadranture donc
il n'y a pas d'angle droit c'est
complètement bizarre
[Musique]
sur ce rocher il était très compliqué de
faire quoi que ce soit de symétrie
pour satisfaire les exigences du
commanditaire les ouvriers vont réaliser
un véritable tour de force
il décide de construire une extension
sur l'eau un petit château en avant de
la forteresse qui servira de hall
d'entrée majestueux pour les invités
[Musique]
et pour réaliser cette incroyable défi
de construire sur l'eau ils vont
s'inspirer de la plus grande ville
flottante au monde
donc ils ont construit le petit château
de la même façon qui a été construit la
ville de Venise ils ont enfoncé des
piliers en bois dans la boue sous l'eau
on va mettre en place ce qu'on appelle
parfois des sonnettes ou des moutons qui
sont des sortes de grands-pois on va
faire descendre régulièrement sur le
pieu et tant que le Pieux descend on
continue à l'enfoncer
une méthode qui nécessite plusieurs
précautions techniques sous peine de
voir la structure s'écrouler il faut que
les pilotis soit toujours sous l'eau la
règle d'or c'est celle là parce que
s'ils sont en dehors de l'eau il y a une
zone de contact et de pourrissement qui
peut se faire donc il faut qu'il soit
toujours noyé dans l'eau et par dessus
on fait ce qu'on appelle un radius c'est
un des poutres croisées et on met des
maçonneries qui vont servir de support à
la construction elle-même
grâce à ce système de pilotis des
dizaines de mètres vont pouvoir être
gagné sur l'eau mais très vite un
nouveau problème se pose pour les
bâtisseurs le petit château qui doit
être le nouveau joyau de Chantilly
impose un changement radical dans le
choix des matières premières
[Musique]
là l'objectif c'est que ça soit beau de
l'extérieur élégant esthétique c'est pas
l'objectif du château médiéval
pas question donc d'utiliser la pierre
du rocher comme à l'époque médiévale
[Musique]
il faut trouver un nouveau gisement mais
où
[Musique]
nous sommes à Saint-Maximin dans l'Oise
à 6 mètres sous terre
ici se trouve des galeries gigantesques
que connaît par cœur Denis montagne son
métier inspecteur de carrière
souterraine
voyez le décollement là
une fracturation naturelle la grande là
donc c'est la pierre tombale assurée là
si vous passez en sous le mauvais jour
aujourd'hui sous surveillance ces
carrières sont une chance incroyable
pour les ouvriers de chantilly à la
Renaissance
elles sont situées seulement à 7 km du
chantier
grosso modo depuis 2001 vous avez une
activité extractive on a la chance
d'avoir un des plus grands sites
carriers de France avec une pierre de
qualité et qui a fourni partout pour
toutes les époques
donc il a servi toute la construction de
Paris construction de Versailles tous
les grands châteaux
si ces carrières sont si prisées c'est
qu'elles abritent une pierre d'une
qualité exceptionnelle
c'est une bière homogène qualité
mécanique kebel qui est réputé donc elle
se taille bien vous vous la rayez à
l'ongle elle se travaille bien à l'outil
elle a tout pour plaire quoi une pierre
assez blonde qui joue bien avec le
soleil de Picardie et puis c'est une une
pierre qui permet en effet des
sculptures de très très bonne qualité
mais avant de sculpter la pierre il faut
l'extraire à la Renaissance les ouvriers
de Chantilly n'avaient qu'un seul outil
à leur disposition une sorte de piolet
très rudimentaire
vous allez enlever de la pierre de
manière régulière
sous toute la surface que vous voulez
extraire
les tailleurs de pierre répètent alors
l'opération de chaque côté du bloc
et à ce moment-là le bloc va se détacher
c'est un travail éreintant
donc vous avez un rendement pour
quelqu'un qui travaille une dizaine
d'heures par jour d'un mètre cube par
semaine
sachant que le bâtiment a construit fait
60 mètres par 30 mètres
le chantier du Petit Château prend
beaucoup de temps trop au bout du
commanditaire
ils sont toujours
sous la pression de finir les travaux au
bon moment parce que le connétable va
venir parce que la Cour va venir et
parfois du coup ils sont obligés de
travailler très vite et peut-être trop
vite pour pouvoir avancer dans les temps
et on voit notamment qu'une partie de la
fondation du petit château n'est pas
très très bien faite avec des matériaux
de récupération qu'on a mis très très
vite en oeuvre ça il est assez probable
que c'est une contrainte pas du tout
technique mais que c'est une contrainte
qui est liée à un commanditaire exigeant
qui trouve que le chantier n'avance pas
assez vite
[Musique]
ce qui aura pour conséquence un
affaissement du plancher de 8 cm 5
siècles plus tard
[Musique]
toujours est-il qu'à l'époque tout
semble tenir
le nouveau bâtiment est terminé en
seulement 6 ans et respecte parfaitement
les exigences du commanditaire
une structure rectangulaire à la
géométrie parfaite une superficie
supplémentaire de 2000 mètres carrés le
tout orné de centaines de sculptures
[Musique]
c'est l'élégance la maîtrise
la rigueur une répartition quand même
très mesurée de l'ornement à une vraie
leçon de maîtrise de la géométrie
[Musique]
chantilly est prêt à recevoir et à
éblouir les plus grands rois d'Europe
cela sera le cas avec l'empereur Charles
Quint le monarque le plus puissant à
l'époque
Charles Quint vient à Chantilly il est
tout à fait ébloui il est tellement
ébloui qu'il demande à Montmorency de
lui céder chantilly contre une province
des Pays-Bas rendez compte fait partie à
la renaissance des grands châteaux qui
vont servir de modèle l'architecture
pour toutes les autres constructions
mais ce leadership va être remise en
cause moins d'un siècle plus tard
un nouveau concurrent arrive et va
pousser le château de Chantilly a des
transformations radicales
nous sommes dans les années 1660 sous le
règne de Louis XIV
une nouvelle construction est au centre
de toutes les attentions
il s'agit du château de Versailles
c'est un chantier hors-nord des sommes
considérables qui ont été qui ont été
dépensés c'est 1400 fontaines enfin
c'est ses délirants il faut bien dire
que personne ne peut rivaliser avec
Versailles et ça c'est très clair pour
tout le monde
pour tout le monde sauf un le nouveau
propriétaire du château de Chantilly il
s'appelle le Grand Condé c'est le cousin
du roi et son plus grand rival
la pensée grande partie de sa fortune en
combattant droit parce qu'il voulait
devenir calife à la place du calife et
ça n'a pas marché donc à la fin elle a
été puni et enfermée dans son château
et donc que va-t-il faire et bien il va
se lancer dans une nouvelle bataille
cette bataille contre le Roi Soleil le
prince déchu ne va pas l'amener sur
l'architecture du château mais sur un
autre aspect du domaine
donc et c'est concentré sur l'autre
sujet à la mode à cette époque c'était
justement les jardins le jardin de la
française est inventé tous les nobles de
France veulent créer des jardins à la
française qui sont très à la mode comme
tout simplement symbole de leur
puissance de la richesse et les grands
condés veut montrer qu'il est presque
voir aussi puissant que le Roi à
Versailles
le projet est extrêmement ambitieux
chantilly étant toujours entouré d'une
gigantesque zone marécageuse
à l'époque une seule personne semble en
mesure de relever pareil défi
mais problème quand le Grand Condé le
contact André Le Nôtre est déjà pris sur
un autre projet d'envergure
Louis XIV le choisit pour aménager les
jardins de Versailles je pense que pour
le nôtre qui était Versailles c'était
une chose qui était pas évidente il
était attaché au domaine de Royal et
tous les autres domaines étaient des
domaines secondaires
chantilly n'est pas un domaine comme les
autres ici se trouve un élément rare et
longtemps considéré comme une faiblesse
une rivière qu'est-ce qu'on a à
Chantilly en grande richesse on le voit
en arrivant c'est l'eau il y a beaucoup
d'eau c'est quand même fantastique à
Versailles il y en a pas mais encore
faut-il savoir la maîtriser
André Le Nôtre donne son accord il
accepte de mener de front les deux
chantiers
il ne le sait pas encore mais il va
réussir à Chantilly des prouesses
techniques qui vont dépasser celle du
château de Versailles
[Musique]
en 1662 les travaux sont lancés
premier objectif assainir la zone
marécageuse
pour arriver à assécher ce genre de
terrain il faudrait mais c'est à dire
qu'il faut essayer de faire arriver
toutes les eaux de part et d'autre sur
un canal central
la zone A drainée est considérable
presque 7000 hectares autant que Paris
intra-muros
[Musique]
le nôtre imagine alors un canal aux
dimensions gigantesques 60 mètres de
large sur 2500 mètres de long
autant qu'une piste d'atterrissage
d'avions de ligne le but assécher les
marécages
les travaux de terrassement et de
percement des canaux vont être colossaux
dans les dans les documents d'archives
on trouve régulièrement mention d'équipe
de 200 ouvriers qui doivent creuser
percer évacuer la terre pour donner
naissance à ses canaux
150 000 mètres cubes de terre sont
décaissés
de quoi remplir plus de 5700
semi-remorques
le grand canal oui ça a été un effort
énorme pour les équipes qui ont dû
travailler ici
les ouvriers vont rencontrer un autre
problème
en creusant dans le sol la nappe
phréatique qui est peu profonde à
Chantilly remonte
ce qui rend le drainage impossible André
Le Nôtre va devoir étancherifier le fond
de son Grand Canal
tue du site et il a pu créer des canaux
qui la recouvert d'argile afin d'isoler
effectivement le fond de son canal et
d'éviter que les eaux de la nappe
remontent et remplissent ces canaux à ce
moment là le fond de son canal étant
bien isolé sur les berges de son canal
on pouvait drainer les eaux des eaux
humides
après deux ans d'un chantier colossal le
drainage est lancé
les terres s'assent la rivière est
maîtrisée
à la vue de ce Grand Canal
le rival du roi jubile
pour vous donner un ordi dès le canal de
Versailles fait 1 km celui de Chantilly
en fait 2 km et demi
[Musique]
mais il reste encore énormément de
travail pour concurrencer Versailles
le chantier entre alors dans sa deuxième
phase celle du découpage très symétrique
du paysage
les routes sont élargies un axe
gigantesque est créé du nord au sud
12 km de perspective c'est la plus
grande perspective de France encore
aujourd'hui
de part et d'autre de la perspective se
dessine des formes géométriques au
milieu de par terre aux dimensions
impressionnantes
il faut savoir que le grand parterre de
Chantilly en superficie ces 6 terrains
de football pour vous donner une échelle
donc c'est pas neutre quand même
mais comment réaliser des symétries
parfaites sur de telles distances
à l'époque les ouvriers ne disposent que
d'une corde à nœud et de perche pour
définir les tracés c'est sans compter
sur l'incroyable talent d'André Le Nôtre
adapter la symétrie à l'oeil humain pour
que même si c'est pas exactement
symétrique qu'on a l'impression que
c'était le cas c'est vraiment un génie
pour ça c'est à dire que c'est calculé
la longueur qu'il faut donner à un
bassin pour que même si les
rectangulaires et l'air d'un carré un
savoir-faire prodigieux qui transforme
peu à peu les termes marécageuses de
Chantilly en parterre parfaitement
ordonnée le rêve du grand Condé prend
forme
mais le chantier va connaître plusieurs
coups d'arrêt qui vont mettre en péril
le projet
[Musique]
alors le problème du grand Condé c'est
qu'il arrive très difficilement à avoir
son architecte paysagiste sur le site
parce qu'il est toujours retenu par le
Roi à Versailles c'est une vie moderne
d'une star
c'est à dire que il vient un jour deux
jours à Chantilly quand il vient alors
là c'est le branle-bas de combat c'est à
dire tout le monde doit être à son
écoute on doit
recueillir ses avis
faire dessiner des esquisses
organiser les travaux jusqu'à sa
prochaine venue et ça on a
d'innombrables lettres ou il faut faire
venir monsieur le nôtre il faut que
Monsieur Le Nôtre soit là et on voit que
chaque fois Monsieur Le Nôtre a une
bonne raison de ne pas être à Chantilly
parce qu'il est à Versailles on a aussi
une rivalité qui aura André Le Nôtre sur
place
[Musique]
le prince de Chantilly ira même jusqu'à
affréter un véhicule spécialement pour
l'architecte pour qu'il puisse revenir
travailler au château
car il lui reste encore un dernier
élément à créer et non des moindres la
création de jeux d'eau capable de couler
en continu ce qui représente à l'époque
une prouesse technique exceptionnelle
[Musique]
maîtriser l'hydraulique qui garde encore
un côté un peu magique pour les hommes
du commun à l'époque ça c'est la vraie
preuve du pouvoir et donc plus un jardin
aura de jeux d'eau plus la preuve du
pouvoir du propriétaire du domaine sera
apportée
André Le Nôtre mesure l'ampleur de la
tâche qui l'attend lui qui a toutes les
peines du monde à faire fonctionner les
fontaines de Versailles
Versailles on a quand même souligné que
ça peut être parfois quand ça marche 20
minutes c'est bien le diable et ça fuit
tant que ça peut on a même imaginé
d'ailleurs à versa une manière de
montrer des jardins
il faisait couler les fontaines
seulement quand le roi se baladait dans
le parc et encore en fonction de là où
il se trouvait quand le roi se baladait
dans les différentes zones du parc il y
avait des petits ouvriers qui couraient
derrière qui ouvrait les fontaines quand
il arrivait et qu'il est fermé tout de
suite derrière
comment andrer le notre va réussir à
Chantilly ce qu'il n'a pas réussi à
faire avec ça
[Musique]
c'est seulement 300 ans plus tard que le
mystère sera levé
quand en 1994 un ancien ingénieur
découvre un bâtiment à l'abandon à
proximité du parc de Chantilly
j'apercevais ce bâtiment dans lequel il
y avait aucun mouvement et lorsque je
m'adressais aux habitants qu'est-ce que
ça se bâtiment les journées
la question oui mais quelle machine
personne n'était capable de me répondre
Yves bac aidé par des amis se lance à la
recherche de cette mystérieuse machine
et finit par en trouver des
représentations dans un ouvrage du 18e
siècle
on a commencé la fantasmer on a fait des
plans on a fait des maquettes et puis
voilà
après 18 mois de travail et l'assemblage
de 250 pièces l'énigme est enfin résolue
il s'agit d'une immense pompe à eau
unique en France créé par André Le Nôtre
[Musique]
au XVIIe siècle le seul moyen de créer
des jeux d'eau et d'utiliser la gravité
André Le Nôtre a donc conçu cette
machine pour amener l'eau du canal en
hauteur
bien l'énergie donc provient de l'eau de
la Nonette ça permet d'entraîner cette
roue et cette route a pour but
d'entraîner bien sûr les pompes
aspirantes et refoulantes par le biais
des engrenages en rouet à une lanterne
c'est tout va être renvoyé grâce à des
canalisations sous le toit du dôme du ce
pavillon puis cette eau par une autre
canalisation va regagner un réservoir
absolument gigantesque qui se trouve sur
le plateau de Chantilly en hauteur
au-dessus de la vallée marécageuse
ce réservoir situé à 10 mètres dessus du
parc de Chantilly pouvait contenir à
l'époque 33 millions de litres soit
l'équivalent de 13 piscines olympique
et une fois que l'eau est dans les
réservoirs et bien par gravité on
alimente les cascades du domaine
prévu pour l'alimentation des jets d'eau
situés à l'ouest du château ce système
hydraulique s'avère particulièrement
efficace
preuve en est avec les grandes cascades
aujourd'hui disparues
au 17e siècle elles sont considérées
comme le point d'orgue des jardins sans
jet d'eau sur 15 mètres de dénivelé
alors combien de temps fonctionne-t-elle
grâce à la machine de Chantilly
siècle la machine de chantissent de la
plus performante de France non pas à
dire en capacité ou un débit mais en
fait qu'elle tournait régulièrement et
avec le volume du réservoir elle pouvait
couler deux jours sans s'arrêter
sans être obligé de remettre en route la
machine à eau pour remplir le réservoir
vous imaginez deux jours sans
interruption c'est du jamais vu en
France pour des jets d'eau aussi
complexes
mais là où chantilly va définitivement
surpasser Versailles
c'est grâce à un tout autre système créé
par André Le Nôtre et il est d'une
simplicité déconcertante
pour les fontaines situées à l'est du
château la machine est trop loin pour
les alimenter
il faut donc trouver un autre moyen
d'amener l'eau en hauteur
c'est alors qu'ils découvert un ancien
acte caché dans les bois
quand arrive à Chantilly il découvre cet
aqueduc du prince dans les bois il est
émerveillé par cette arrivée d'eau qui
est en hauteur par rapport au parterre à
la française 9 mètres de différence
une source surélevée qui coule en
continu André Le Nôtre sans qu'il touche
au but
il crée alors une dérivation de 5 mètres
pour alimenter un énorme bassin de
charge de 40 000 litres d'eau
donc depuis ce bassin de charge vous
avez un ensemble de tuyaux qui partent
littéralement dans tous les sens qui
passe sous la terre et qui vont vers les
bassins
pour créer un accélération des courants
on réduit en fait le diamètre c'est un
peu l'effet aussi d'un jet d'eau quand
on tourne la buse plus on réduit le
diamètre plus l'eau va vite donc ça
permet de créer du courant
l'exploit est en marche
à Chantilly qui avait les fontaines qui
marchaient en continu à l'époque ça
s'appelait le miracle des autres
c'est vraiment exceptionnel mais
vraiment
au total c'est plus de 7 km de tuyaux
souterrains qui alimente tous les jeux
d'eau à Chantilly le Paris est réussi la
nature est domptée
[Musique]
ne reste plus qu'à montrer cette
prouesse au monde entier
le 23 avril 1671 le prince invite à
Chantilly son cousin le Roi Soleil pour
trois jours de fête
alors comment va réagir celui qui
condamne à mort qui compte lui fait de
l'ombre
il a 2000 personnes c'est vraiment l'un
des principaux événements à Chantilly du
vivant du grand Condé c'est l'époque où
les jardins sont en grande partie
terminée et donc il va accueillir
son coup de camp que toute cette
magnificence est faite pour lui
fin de stratagème le Grand Condé laisse
le roi croire qu'il a transformé
chantilly pour lui
le roi s'émerveille
le Grand Condé savoure
je ne sais pas si vous imaginez l'effet
que ça a pu faire à Louis XIV quand il
était invité par le Grand Condé et celui
en pleine nuit ça marchait il allait le
soir ça marchait il y a le matin ça
marchait c'est un effet de vête
saisissant pour lui quand même
et grâce à tous ces jeux d'eau avec ces
grandes réussites d'André Le Nôtre en
cela chantit dépasse Versailles
définitivement
on s'en sort intérieur prend un peu
comme une vengeance face au roi pourquoi
pas
les années passent les générations se
succèdent à Chantilly
mais la rivalité avec Versailles
continue
même après la mort du Roi Soleil
les travaux Versailles se sont arrêtés
net à ce moment-là et tous les ouvriers
se trouvaient un peu sans grand chose à
faire et donc le prince a chanté le
principe qu'on dit écouter les gars moi
aussi j'ai un château venez chez moi
cette nouvelle main d'oeuvre va changer
radicalement le visage de Chantilly
à commencer par les façades du grand
château
on a changé toutes les parties hautes
donc il faut imaginer des sortes de
grandes tours et puis au sommet on a
placé des lanternants on a placé des
toitures on a ouvert complètement les
murs par un très très grand nombre de
fenêtres
les modifications se poursuivent à
l'intérieur c'est le cas dans le petit
château devenu entre-temps le lieu de
vie des princes de Chantilly
on va créer une grande galerie comme la
galerie des glaces
avec les mêmes dispositifs c'est à dire
que vous allez avoir des baies qui sont
les baies de la Renaissance qui vont
être agrandis et aménagés et de l'autre
côté on va obstruer les baies de la
Renaissance pour y placer des miroirs de
sorte que la lumière des baies va
pouvoir se refléter sur les miroirs
placés juste en face comme dans galerie
des Glaces de versa donc c'est un petit
Versailles
mais là où le savoir-faire de ces
ouvriers Versailles va être mis à rude
épreuve c'est dans la construction à
Chantilly d'un nouveau bâtiment qui va
battre tous les records
[Musique]
situés à 300 mètres du château voici les
écuries princières les plus grandes
d'Europe
ces grandes écuries sont plus grandes
que le château lui-même et c'est
quasiment unique dans les châteaux
français ou européen en fait c'est la
même longueur que la façade des
Invalides 186 mètres de long 25 mètres
de large c'est incroyable
absolument incroyable
divisé en deux nef gigantesques capables
d'accueillir 240 chevaux
ornée de sculptures d'une finesse
exceptionnelle
ce temple du cheval rivalise avec les
écuries royales
mais c'est un chantier tout à fait
démesuré qui va engloutir des millions
et des millions
pourtant ce chantier qui va durer plus
de 20 ans et qui tournera au cauchemar
pour les ouvriers avec commencer par une
bonne surprise
on se rend compte qu'en fait sous la
pelouse de Chantilly existe la pierre
qu'on utilise encore à l'époque qui est
la pierre de Saint-Maximin des pierres à
100 mètres de la porte des grandes
écuries une source naturelle de pierre
mais gigantesque deux hectares et demi
de pierre à tailler dans le brut
pour un bâtiment élégante écuries fin je
veux dire c'est formidable
aussi incroyable que cela puisse
paraître
sous les grandes écuries se cachent un
labyrinthe aussi grand que trois
terrains de football
à l'époque ce n'est pas moins de 50000
blocs de pierres qui vont être extraits
par ces grands trous creusés dans la
roche
[Musique]
ces cheminées elles ont deux fonctions
la première les flux des et puis la
deuxième c'est aussi l'extraction des
pierres puisque on y mettait des pièces
de bois les charpente et avec un système
de poulie on remontait les pierres à la
surface un gain de temps et un gain
d'argent parce que dans un budget de
construction d'un bâtiment comme celui
des grandes écuries la part de l'achat
de la pierre mais aussi de son
acheminement et considère
ce n'est pas le seul avantage dont les
bâtisseurs vont bénéficier
et notamment lors de la construction de
la pièce maîtresse des écuries
le dôme a des dimensions exceptionnelles
pour un dôme d'écurie il fait 28 mètres
de haut à l'intérieur sur 20 mètres de
large
c'est un chef-d'œuvre de la taille de
pierre mais
les constructeurs français sont très
forts sont très habiles ils maîtrisent
la technologie
un savoir-faire indéniable mais qui va
nécessiter certains ajustements en
raison de la taille XXL du dôme
c'est ce que nous explique Jean-Michel
Bouchard companion tailleur de pierre et
Meilleur Ouvrier de France
quand on fait un dôme à 28 mètres sur
une dimension comme ça il faut
contrecarrer les pousser de ces pierres
qu'on met on met plusieurs tonnes de
pierre on les clave on taille tous les
cailloux à une certaine forme pour que
les poussées verticales soient
repoussées en horizontal qu'elle part en
oblique et qu'à la fin elle redescende
dans les murs de chaque côté
on a 5 mètres d'épaisseur pour
contrebalancer justement la poussée de
ses voûtes la promesse architecturale en
quelque sorte là dedans c'est qu'on sera
absolument pas compte qu'on avait mûrs
qui sont plus épais que dans n'importe
quel château médiéval
pour s'assurer que le dôme ne s'écroule
pas
les ouvriers vont également ajouter un
autre matériau
le métal
[Musique]
les constructeurs avaient la prudence en
fait d'introduire des éléments
métalliques qui peut être à l'assemblage
entre les pierres la pour renforcer la
tenue mécanique de l'ensemble
des prouesses architecturales d'autant
plus exceptionnelles
qu'elles sont réalisées dans des
conditions de travail épouvantables
on sait par exemple que le prince de
Condé paye un chirurgien sur place pour
s'occuper des ouvriers blessés et on a
également des témoignages sur les
accidents de chantier par exemple des
échafaudages qui s'effondre alors que
les ouvriers sont dessus et donc
évidemment plusieurs d'entre eux sont
blessés
mais il y a pire
les ouvriers doivent faire face à une
autre menace pour le moins inattendu
Nicole Garnier est la conservatrice en
chef du Domaine de Chantilly
lors de travaux de rénovation en 2008
elle est ses équipes ont fait une
macabre découverte
et on a trouvé ce crâne humain donc qui
a été transmis à la gendarmerie qui a
fait les analyses nécessaires
visiblement il s'agit d'un homicide
puisqu'il y a une trace de balle donc il
ressort de l'autre côté l'analyse au
carbone 14 qui était faite par les
gendarmes a indiqué que ce cet homme ou
cette femme en ignore le sexe a été tué
entre 1650 et 1950
d'après certaines archives ce crâne
pourrait être celui de l'un des ouvriers
du chantier des grandes écuries
une des hypothèses c'est effectivement
le compte de charolais donc qui était le
gestionnaire du domaine de Chantilly et
dont on sait qu'il a tué certains des
ouvriers qui travaillaient sur cette
terre
les ouvriers de toiture pour s'entraîner
au tir
en tout cas ça fait partie des
nombreuses légendes de Chantilly et
notamment des légendes noires de
Chantilly
ce n'est pas ce possible homicide qui
arrêtera le chantier des grandes écuries
mais la mort du commanditaire en 1740
quand on voit aujourd'hui les grandes
écuries on se rend compte qu'il y a des
parements de pierre qui attendaient une
suite et puis notamment il y a un
pavillon qui n'a jamais été construit
en effet seule la porte de ce pavillon a
été terminée
à côté nous apercevons les pierres sur
lesquelles devaient s'emboîter les murs
de ce bâtiment
les grandes écuries restent donc
inachevées mais sont une prouesse
architecturale exceptionnelle
à la fin du 18e siècle le Domaine de
Chantilly est au sommet de sa splendeur
chantilly n'a jamais été aussi beau et
chantilly et vraiment réputé dans
l'Europe entière et va recevoir des
invités venus de toute l'Europe
une apogée qui sera de courte durée car
tout bascule le 14 juillet 1789
la révolution éclate à Paris
la Bastille est prise le pouvoir est
renversé dès lors tout symbole de
l'ancien régime est détruit par les
révolutionnaires
chantilly n'est pas épargné
chantilly va être confisqué va être
vendue comme bien d'immigrés fondu à des
démolisseurs le château est peu à peu
démonté et on met en vente tout ce qu'on
peut en terme de matériaux donc les
plombs des toitures les ardoises et
toute la pierre de taille et une grande
partie de la ville de Chantilly actuelle
a été construite avec les pierres qui
viennent du grand château
en 8 ans c'est plus de 500 ans
d'histoire qui disparaissent
le grand château est rasé au niveau de
ses fondations les jardins de Lenôtre
sont en ruine
seul reste le petit château et les
grandes écuries
la Révolution française c'est le
désastre complet c'est le grand vide
chantilly se trouve face au plus grand
défi technique de son histoire
impossible d'imaginer que deux siècles
plus tard le château sera de nouveau
debout
cette exploit on le doit à l'obsession
d'un petit garçon
[Musique]
le duc d'hommage
hérite de Chantilly en 1830 et il a 8
ans
alors la renaissance de Chantilly va se
faire avec un enfant de 8 ans Henri
d'Orléans Dube mal donc le cinquième
fils du roi Louis-Philippe le dernier
roi des Français
après un exil forcé de 30 ans en
Angleterre il lance en 1875 un chantier
titanesque de reconstruction
ce château a coûté des millions de
francs des époques le duc de mal était
dans l'un des hommes les plus riches de
son temps et c'était finalement l'œuvre
de sa vie qui déployait ici
pour réaliser son rêve le nouveau
propriétaire de Chantilly va imposer au
bâtisseurs un cahier des charges
particulièrement contraignant
tout d'abord pas question de construire
le château ailleurs que sur le rocher
alors coutume de dire mes prédécesseurs
ont bâti leur château à cet endroit-là
public siècle et je ferai de même
niveau architecture le château doit être
réalisé dans un style Renaissance
il va faire ce qu'on appelle en
architecture des citations comme par
exemple la porte d'entrée du château de
Chantilly qui est une copie de la porte
du batistère du château de Fontainebleau
il va copier la chapelle des coins
[Musique]
ces grandes tours à clocher du château
de Chantilly elle elles vont s'inspirer
aussi bien de Chambord que de
valencennes monument ancien
et pour que l'illusion soit parfaite les
ouvriers doivent à tout prix dissimuler
les matériaux modernes qu'ils utilisent
c'est le cas avec l'éclairage de la plus
grande salle du nouveau château la
galerie des peintures
ici 85 des 815 tableaux que possède le
duc de Chantilly sont exposés
au plafond des carreaux de verre striés
qui cachent une verrière ultra moderne
pour l'époque
elle se constitue d'une couverture
vitrée longue d'une dizaine de mètres et
d'une charpente métallique composée de 8
arcs en acier riveté
c'est le matériau du XIXe siècle ça
coûte pas beaucoup d'argent ça va vite
c'est efficace
des techniques révolutionnaires pour le
19e siècle mais totalement anachronique
pour un château d'inspiration 16e siècle
les ouvriers vont donc rajouter des
éléments de toiture tout autour de la
verrière pour la rendre invisible aux
yeux du public
ce qui est impressionnant c'est
promenez-vous en barque
à Chantilly promenez-vous dans les par
terre regardez les toitures vous ne
verrez pas la moindre verrière il y a
toutes les techniques modernes mais bien
cachées quand même pour qu'on n'est pas
l'impression d'être dans un bâtiment
moderne sauf que ce château est plus
jeune que la Tour Eiffel
et par terre d'André Le Nôtre seront
également restaurés grâce aux avancées
technologiques et techniques de l'époque
chantilly renaît de ses cendres en
seulement 10 ans
c'est toujours cette dernière version de
Chantilly que des milliers de touristes
visitent chaque année
et si rien n'a bougé depuis 120 ans
c'est que le château est extrêmement
bien protégé par le testament du dernier
propriétaire
à sa mort le duc d'omale l'aigle
l'ensemble du domaine à l'Institut de
France sous certaines conditions
il demande expressément que il n'y ait
aucune modification dans l'architecture
extérieur et intérieur du château
une volonté de protéger ses lieux
d'exception qui s'avère être un
véritable casse-tête pour les ouvriers
d'aujourd'hui notamment lors des travaux
de restauration
depuis 2004 60 millions d'euros ont été
investis pour rénover le domaine
à chaque fois la même difficulté comment
réparer son tout changer c'est le cas
ici sur le toit des grandes écuries ou
des poutres vieilles de 300 ans menace
de s'effondrer
[Musique]
les parties altérées ont été purgées et
renforcés et donc ici nous avons utilisé
une technique en conservant la pièce
historique qu'elle est moisée sur ces
deux côtés d'éléments modernes qui
viennent renforcer la structure
et le tout étant voilà cerclé de métal
est obligé de réutiliser les techniques
de l'époque les matériaux de l'époque et
de respecter les lieux tout simplement
chantilly n'est plus un défi près
chantilly n'a pas cessé d'être en
chantier et c'est sans doute aussi la
dimension exceptionnelle du château de
Chantilly on a tous que l'architecture
et l'art des jardins a fait de plus beau
en France au cours des siècles c'est le
plus extraordinaire des patrimoine
français
10 siècles d'histoire et de construction
mouvementée
Milan d'un chantier hors du commun qui
en fait aujourd'hui un symbole de
l'excellence française en matière
d'architecture le château de Chantilly
se voulait la demeure des Princes
les constructeurs ont bâti sa légende
[Musique]